Tonight, meet the Thompsons and the Moraleses,...
...two families who are extra grateful this Thanksgiving.
Debbie Thompson and Chris Morales have been best friends...
...since elementary school in Westminster, California.
Inseparable, cheerleading together in high school.
We got married a year apart.
Yeah, we've just done everything together.
It's just, we're as one.
For sure.
In 2015, Chris received the devastating news...
...that she needed a kidney.
Her best friend didn't hesitate.
I said, "Well, you can have mine".
I mean, it was never even a thought.
She'd make a full recovery and is now healthy.
But what happened next, neither couple could have imagined.
Seven years later, Chris's husband, Ron, was in renal failure...
...and now he needed a kidney, too.
He was in the emergency room, and we just couldn't believe it...
...because I already went through kidney failure,...
...and then now he's going through kidney failure.
Then the call from their friends, the Thompsons,...
...that would change their lives again.
He says, "Do you need a kidney?" And it took me a couple of seconds...
...because I was in awe, and I was like, "Well, yeah, you know, I do".
Look at you, Joe.
Ron's surgery, just like his wife's, was a success.
Both were at Cedars-Sinai in Los Angeles.
Words can't explain how I feel.
I want to let him know that I'll always be there for him...
...for what he's done for me.
Tonight, the Moraleses, grateful.
This Thanksgiving week, we're so grateful and happy,...
...and we just, from the bottom of our hearts, thank you Debbie and Brian,...
...for the gift of life.
Debbie and Brian, going above and beyond, quite the gift.